in the UK it is illegal for you to get a
second wife but you can have a mistress
and a girlfriend inside truck's calm
excuse me I can't have a second wife
that I'm gonna honor and respect and
look after and provide for and treat you
like my wife but I can have mistress and
girlfriends
he will come and say to me and go oh you
only became a Muslim because of the
second third for a wife as a Muslim if I
get married to the first wife I have to
speak to my father protect provide give
her Dowry pray for everything even if
she's rich and then if I get a second
wife I have to do the same and now let's
take me as a non-muslim no rules and
regulations and I can do whatever I like
which one's easier it's hard enough
keeping one woman happy if you said to
your wife I want to bring her into the
family how's that going you better see
that knife
Matrix if any woman comes to me and says
I'm okay with my husband getting a
second wife trust me they're bluffing
you also have to share your resources
with multiple women it depends if you
have game if you've got a game and don't
have money sign up to my course
the true Geordie podcast